der supervulkan unter dem amerikanischen
yellowstone nationalpark ist gigantisch
seine magma kammer ist 40 kilometer
breit und 60 kilometer lang in ihr
brodeln 15.000 kubikmeter magma eine
riesige gefahr fest steht falls der
vulkan ausbricht hätte dieses fatale
folgen für die menschen auf der gesamten
erde
einige medien berichten jetzt über
alarmzeichen die auf einen zeitnahen
ausbruch des vulkans hindeuten könnten
willkommen bei pixum science und fiction
hier gibt es täglich faszinierendes
science videos abonniert den kanal nur
dann verpasste nichts ein horror
szenario vor allem für die us
bundesstaat montana idaho und wyoming
und den gesamten nordamerikanischen
kontinent der ausbruch des yellowstone
vulkans würde glut lawinen aus lava und
asche mit einer temperatur von 800 grad
celsius niedergehen lassen infrastruktur
und landwirtschaft hätten keine chance
mehr die sonne kämen nicht mehr zur erde
durch wolken aus schwefel gas würden
dies verhindern das globale klima kühlt
ab und die ernten in zahlreichen
regionen weltweit fallen aus 74 tage
lang würden uns die weltweiten
nahrungsvorräten überleben lassen danach
würde wohl ein großteil der menschen
verhungern
fachleute sind sie schon lange sicher
dass das komplette leben auf der erde
durch einen ausbruch des super vulkans
bedroht wäre deutlich macht dass auch
das alarmierte statement des nasa
mitarbeiter brian willcox demnach sei
die forschung zu supervulkan weitaus
wichtiger als die entwicklung von
systemen die kometen und asteroiden von
der erde fernhalten und so haben
forschungsteams weltweit den supervulkan
im velo stone nationalpark ganz genau im
blick um auch ja jede kleine veränderung
registrieren zu können im vergangenen
jahr beispielsweise erschien eine
spannende studie die unglaubliche
erkenntnisse zum supervulkan aufgespürt
hatte
denn neue messungen eines us
forschungsteams hatten gezeigt dass ein
schlauch des schmelzendes gestein bis an
die grenze zum erdkern reicht und das
sind unfassbare 2900 kilometer bislang
waren fachleute von einer magma quelle
in einer tiefe von 440 kilometern
ausgegangen doch die bilder die mit
hilfe von erdbebenwellen gewonnen werden
konnten legen nahe dass heißes gestein
von der
erdkern grenze unter mexiko schräg nach
oben quillt und zwar in einer 350
kilometer breiten zone bis in den
nordosten der usa der obere teil der
gestein sonne wärmt darüber liegendes
gestein dennoch geht der geologische
dienst der usa united states geological
survey sgs beispielsweise nicht davon
aus dass eine größere eruption in der
nächsten zeit zu befürchten sei denn
dafür müsse sich der untergrund in der
region stark verändern
ein drittel der magma kammer müsse
geschmolzen sein damit sich der bvi
flüssigkeit verhält messungen aber
zeigen dass derzeit weniger als ein
zehntel des gesteins für sich sind
demnach sei das mag meinen einzelnen
blasen in felsspalten eingeschlossen
die wahrscheinlichkeit dass eine große
eruption des vulkans stattfinden liegt
dem us gs zufolge im jahr bei 1 zu
700.000 im vorfeld würde es dann aber
auch entsprechende anzeichen geben der
vermehrte austritt von gas
beispielsweise oder eine gehäufte anzahl
an beben als ohnehin im yellowstone
könnten als alarmzeichen interpretiert
werden letztendlich würde sich dann wohl
auch der boden durch den magna auf strom
würden einige sperrt experten und
expertinnen sehen sowieso nicht dem
supervulkan selbst als größte bedrohung
sondern die erdbeben in dieser region
dazu der geograf michael pohl und in
einem interview mit usa today
es ist viel weniger der vulkan als
vielmehr die erdbeben die schaden
anrichten können und werden das ist eine
unterschätzte gefahr im yellowstone
gebiet das kann und wird in zukunft
erdbeben der stärke 7 geben pro jahr
werden in der yellowstone region
durchschnittlich 1500 bis 2000 erdbeben
registriert der großteil davon ist
allerdings zu klein um vom menschen
wahrgenommen zu werden
diese übernimmt ein großes netzwerk von
etwa 50 seismometern damit gehört diese
region zu den selbst grafisch am besten
bewachten der ganzen welt einige news
portal und zeitung berichten derzeit
immer wieder darüber dass die
thermischen und seismischen aktivitäten
rund um den supervulkan zugenommen
hätten im herbst 2008 10 zeigten sich
beispielsweise einige geysire im
yellowstone park so aktiv wie nie
in rund zehn metern höhe spiel
beispielsweise eine der heißesten
geysire der gegend gase vulkanisches
gestein und kochend heißes wasser zudem
bilden sich medienberichten zufolge die
zeit weitere geysire fachleute wie die
von yellowstone vulkan auf sehr teuer
aber halten diese ereignisse für nicht
ungewöhnlich demnach stehen diese
vorkommnisse zitat nicht in direktem
zusammenhang mit der bewegung von magma
in mehreren kilometern tiefe
es gibt keine anzeichen für eine
bevorstehende vulkanische aktivität was
passiert also als nächstes ein
gewaltiges erdbeben oder der ausbruch
des vulkans auch wenn experten und
expertinnen beide bedrohung gut
überwachung ist diese frage nicht zu
beantworten statistisch gesehen ist der
schwimmende vulkan jedenfalls überfällig
die drei bisherigen ausbrüche passierten
vor 2,1 millionen jahren von 1,2
millionen jahren und von 640.000 jahren
doch selbst wenn ernst zu nehmende
alarmzeichen beobachtet werden würden
wäre nicht klar welche maßnahmen und
retten könnten
die bio logical society auf landen
beispielsweise hat in einem gutachten
über super vulkane festgestellt dass
keinerlei notfallpläne für solch eine
katastrophe existieren und so tüftelt
die us weltraumbehörde nasa an an
kuriosen plan um den supervulkan zu
entschärfen beziehungsweise einen
ausbruch sogar zu verhindern
ein geothermie kraftwerk in der nähe des
vulkans könnte die lösung sein
demnach müsste der vulkan zunächst
angebohrt werden so könnte ihm das
kraftwerk langsam aber stetig wärme
entziehen und die magmakammer
langfristig abkühlen die geschätzten
kosten des projekts 3,5 milliarden
dollar
doch dadurch würde nicht nur die gefahr
eines ausbruchs eingedämmt bei diesem
plan ließe sich sogar strom gewinnen
zehn kilometer beispielsweise müsste
gebohrt werden um an 350 grad heißes
wasser so lang so ließe sich dann strom
für etwa 10 cent pro kilowattstunde
herstellen falls das projekt erfolgreich
wäre könnte die region um den vulkan
wohl für mehrere hundert jahre mit strom
versorgt werden aber klar ist auch die
idee der nasa birgt große risiken denn
solch eine bedrohung könnte tatsächlich
die katastrophe auslösen die es
eigentlich zu verhindern gilt die
magmakammer könnte instabil werden wenn
unternehmen in die tieferen und heißeren
schichten bohren die folge
der ausbruch der supervulkan schon hier
in europa haben die bohrung für
geothermie kraftwerke zur erdbeben
geführt
die drohende katastrophe eines teilchens
sturms das ist im moment jedenfalls eine
größere gefahr hier draufklicken
anschauen und doktor watson abonnieren
bis dann bleibt dran